if you're a fan of The Last of Us video
games that the series was based on then
you know that season 1 of the hit HBO
series stuck fairly close to the source
material we can't be sure just yet that
the second season will do exactly the
same but it's safe to assume that the
story is headed in a similar Direction
at the very least if that is what
happens then this story is going some
pretty wild places and things are about
to get a lot darker according to writer
and Creator Craig Mason we were able to
to map out all of season 2 and I also
wrote and submitted the script for the
first episode and sent it to HBO around
10:30 or 10:40 p.m. right before the
midnight that midnight the wga strike
began Mason has also said that the
season has been outlined in its entirety
still the SAG after strike means that
the actors may not know the broad
Strokes of season 2 other than what they
know from the game